欢迎收看理财大人秀的筹码教学单元
歌有筹必报
好,我们的歌叫做全正小歌
那大家想说
歌你是不是很久没有讲全正了
好,但是歌今天呢
他来要讲跟全正相关
可是不是讲全正
而且很好用哦
大家有没有发现哦
这个磐式啊
在這個15000到16000之間震盪的時候
很多股票現在走勢越來越誇張了
常常今天拉一根大長紅
甚至盤中拉到快漲停
結果收盤啪啪啪啪快要跌停
還有就是隔天貨通通倒出來
那我們之前有教大家看隔日沖的券商有沒有
那你會說有時候我看也不是隔日沖的券商在搞鬼
到底發生什麼事了
好那就是誰
那就是你不知道的全鎮大戶
也會來給你玩隔日沖喔
所以今天小哥要來教你認識
什麼叫做全鎮大戶
其實跟著全鎮大戶做
勝率也很高
只是做法不太一樣
不太一樣喔
有人看到投信大戶一直買一直買
就覺得跟著做會往上漲
也沒錯
可是全鎮大戶突然大買
不見得要跟著買對不對
對啊
因為全鎮大戶大部分都是比較短
比較短
跟我一樣比較短一點
短線一點
我們為什麼要小心全鎮隔日沖的賣壓
因為第一個 今天的全鎮買盤
就很容易變成隔天的全鎮賣盤
他就只做一天
所以今天買明天
跟證券的隔日沖也差不多
對 也很像
只不過證券隔日沖他們很多都喜歡去鎖長田
那全鎮隔日沖只要今天搶四股他們就買
明天就賣掉
第二個
全鎮隔衝大物進場,他會大量買進全鎮
他買了全鎮之後呢
自營商要做什麼事呢?自營商就要買股票避險
好,所以他是逼自營商去幫他拉股價
幫他拉股價,那自營商買股票避險
還會怎麼樣你知道嗎?
自營商買股票避險,那股票就容易漲嘛對不對?
那股票漲了之後,自營商還要再買更多股票來避險
是
所以呢,很容易今天全鎮大物進來的
它就是一個良性循環
今天股票漲了 全鎮又進來買
全鎮進來買之後呢
自營商只好再買
買了之後又漲 漲了又買 買了又漲
就一直漲上去
好過癮喔
所以盤中要知道自營商今天買什麼股票
這個還蠻重要的
我們盤中都會看
哇 今天這樣股票好強啊
很多全鎮大陸進來買
那我們今天就偏多做
那明天一早趕快賣掉
因為全鎮大陸明天一早就要到全鎮了
那第三個呢
當大陸隔天賣出手上權證的時候
那自營商呢
他就沒有避險需求了
你昨天你買我要去避險
你今天你賣了
那我就要趕快把限國給賣掉
那這個呢就會造成賣壓
那今天呢他的走勢就不會那麼強
是
就比較弱一點
但是這是鐵律嗎
就是以前隔日沖發現
行情好會三日沖
權證會不會變三日沖
也有
也有是不是
假如他很強的話會這樣
那假如他每天都一紅一黑一紅一黑的話
那代表他可能沒那麼強
是
很強的話會怎麼樣你知道嗎
早上9點到全震
是
然後到完之後股票不是跌下來
對
跌下來之後又漲回去
因為又有人進來買
然後到10點的時候
我又進來買
就全震大會原本倒光了
今天又進來買回來
這個我們也蠻常見的
這麼靈敏
對
這麼靈敏我要怎麼追蹤
很難啊
至少我們前半段的賣壓
我們可以跟得到
是
那昨天的這個追價我們也追得到
只要你有這個好的軟體來輔助你
是
這個其實我們常常跟大家宣導
籌碼軟體要有比較多功能的話
還是要花一點費用
好 那這個我們常見
這些你可以在證交所的一些籌碼資料也看得到
那常見的全證歌聰大戶
我們常看到第一個有原婦
還有原富松德
那原富跟原富松德最近買的還蠻多的
總之都是原富只是分點不一樣
對分點不一樣
那第二個呢
原大台南、原大相商、原大文新
原大系列
這也是格日聰分點
那我們通常看到格日聰分點
買在哪一家券商呢
大概就可以判斷一下
可能這家券商的最近的系統做得比較好是這樣為什麼呢因為這些全證的格衆大戶他們抓的就是時間差所以他們的系統好才抓得到時間差
這麼厲害
很厲害
因為全證是券商
那個發行商在造勢
對
只要他們造勢的速度稍微慢一點
就會被他們吃豆腐
是
例如說股票漲了
那全證好像還沒反應
全證就會被吃豆腐
所以最近看起來
而元富是比較會吃豆腐的
那以前呢
其實這些交易人
他以前債的分點是不大一樣
他會換
以前還在元大或者是在永豐
最近看起來債元富比較多
是
好
那我們來看結論
假設股價上場是自行商避險買進造成的
因為有時候我們會看到
今天奇怪了
今天漲3%
可是外資賣投信也賣
只剩自行商買
而且有時候自己商還買蠻多
對,這種的話
這種的話你要去看一下
這全證是誰買的
是
假設全證是這五個買的
哦
明天早上趕快賣
好
你不賣的話
等到這些全證大會賣出來
你的股票可能就跌下來
尤其是行情其實沒有非常強勢的時候
對,沒有非常強勢的話
通常都是一紅一黑哦
那你早上賣
看它跌回來你還可以再買回來
是
這個做點業績
好
那以後的手續還可以打個折
是
又繳點稅
我覺得還不錯啦
因為呢
只要它不是波段阻力買進
很容易就只有一天的行情喔
但是呢
大家也會問了
所以這五家
怎麼講
五家分點
就有點像是我們看
平常買股票的隔日充分點
先記起來
記起來
以後有陸續增加
我們再幫大家update對不對
對對對
再跟各位update一下
好 希望他們不要換分點
被小哥講完就破解了
他們通常不好換
因為他在這個分點
這個待久了
他的手續率可能都很低了
第一個手續率很低
第二個系統很習慣了
所以他們通常也不大會換
算了被小哥吃吃豆腐算了
很多人吃他豆腐不只我
好 那要去哪找對不對
那每天很多人都會想說
那我要去找這支要怎麼找
我這邊放一個不用錢的
不用錢的
不用錢的 免費的
不用錢的最貴喔
這個不用錢 我們要注意
全鎮小哥的FB
每天晚上我們貼在粉絲頁
我跟你講小哥很拽的
他很早就有藍勾勾
不像我們後面的人搞那麼辛苦
藍勾勾很久了
藍勾勾不要被詐騙集團騙去了
這個藍勾勾
而且我們的粉絲數已經快到15萬人
追蹤人數快到15萬
你知道為什麼這麼多嗎
貼了十年
你這張表貼了十年啊
貼十年的
主力忍你忍十年
這張表很多人在看的
每天看一下說
今天短線主力買哪些
明天可能早上就會有點賣
所以貼了十年
慢慢的才積累到四五萬
不然我平常又沒有露什麼
乳酵之類的
我也沒有辦法 糟糕
所以這個
平常也沒辦法累積這些粉絲
這些粉絲啊
所以慢慢看
粉絲又越來越多
好
我們來看一下
這個主力收錶
像這個是5月16號
5月16號就看到
元泰啊
他是買超認購的排行榜
有元泰、鴻海、德威、台積電
這幾檔
這樣一看會以為是很好的事情啊
主力大買超啊
主力大買超
可是你要去看一下
原來不是這樣看喔
買超的分點是比較波段的還是短線
像昨天的元泰是波段的
會放比較久
波段的也有分厲害的跟肉角的
厲害的我們會稍微跟一下
肉角的就趕快離開一點
因為有的人看他錢真的很多
每次買錢真的都買波段
每次波段都賠人產
那種大戶就不能跟
厲害的就可以跟
其實我記得你以前在節目上面有分享過波段的全鎮大戶
他們如果買多還真的就會有一波行情
但是可能最近看起來短線的比較多
短線比較多
波段的最近也怕有些不厲害的
買波段有的是澳單
澳久了澳到受不了他們就會砍出來
我有看過小哥的那個開股東會的那個
那個叫什麼通知單
因為我說你也曾經澳單澳成大股東嗎
後來才好不容易出掉
不是 我也是這樣子
本來只想隔日沖
結果變成大股東
你也會了
那天買了之後我本來想隔天賣掉發現他隔天真的沒有亮害我賣了好多天本來有1400張賣到剩800張的時候 停止過戶事
我就變成是那個大股東
所以我可以拿800張的通知書去開會
所以大家不要看到有誰買到
前十大股東通知趙華說
小哥有入主這一家 有時候是意外
有時候是意外
今天有個新聞你知道嗎
航海王 長榮第七名
有一位陳先生對不對
張先生
對 他剛剛有是
超人第一名
比那個老闆娘還多
好 總之小哥每天都會貼
但是看法要留意了
這個認購全證的買超排行
假設都是現在隔日沖在玩
其實買超的不利喔
隔天通常有賣壓
那可是如果是認購全證的賣超呢
他今天賣一大堆呢
哇 這個造法厲害
看到重點了
假設他今天賣
然後隔天再轉牆的話
隔天很容易又變成買超
因為他們的節奏就這樣
所以反而是賣超的
你可以特別看一下
他可能賣超今天黑K
那明天他全震又會再買回來
所以你要懂他的節奏
反而多看賣超這一邊
賣超這邊的有可能是明天往上攻的主角
那買超這邊的
隔天早上10點會有壓力
那我再問一個問題
因為你貼10年
但我大概看了兩年了
有時候兩邊會同樣的股票
會出現同樣的股票
認購跟認售會同時出現
對
就是他又主力買認購
又主力買認售
通常這種股票就是超級熱門股
那什麼
就是融資跟融券暴增
那這種股票假如爆大量的話
那大概就高點蠻近的
好 兩邊都有
但是爆大量還是以偏空為主
好 你看我都有在follow你喔
哇 厲害 真的
那我要特別講一個很有趣的事情
以前有個學員他就跟我講
小哥 我每天看你主力收購認購全證買超排行
我從第一名買到第五名
全證主力在加持
我每天一找我就九點進去買
很奇怪到九點半我都賠錢
所以等於反的做勝率真的蠻高
真的蠻高
我說你就做反了
因為人家九點到九點半要到貨
你還買你還特別買九點
所以你要知道它的節奏
節奏非常重要
這張表請大家按時去小哥的粉絲團看
多追蹤
15萬 趕快變成20萬
好 接下來看這個實力
實際案例 我們錄影前一天
直接找錄影前一天的資料 最新鮮的
來看一下在5月15號
買超第一名的叫東元
那我們可以看到買超第二名剩下500多萬
所以这一天的盘肯定是不好
盘好的话就一堆
就前数名都1000万以上
1000万以上
这天盘不好
但是盘不好呢
还是有一些标记可以买
那这种买超冬元的在5月15号
在5月16号
早上呢
在我的全方位软件
我们就看到冬元就一排卖购
一排卖购
所以5月16号早上
冬元就比较弱一点
所以呢
可以按照这个你可以抓到节奏
可是5月16号
其實那一天是大漲
對 照好講得很好
大漲200多點 然後大家都在講
為什麼會大漲 好像沒有理由
只有巴菲特把台積電賣光
巴韭菜賣光台積電
往上漲了
舉國歡騰耶 沒有賣壓了
以後不能去跟他吃飯
他說你敢罵我韭菜
他應該不懂韭菜的中文
知道
古彩
我們來看這個全正賣
這個東元我們來看西一點
東元買超第一名的是元大向上
就剛剛有講
對 向上 西螺 文金
我猜這三個都是同一個人
這些中部人也蠻猛的
對 而且他們前天買完
隔天都會到
各位看一下 你看
他在5月15號大買 5月15號大買
5月16號就到貨
他是標準的隔日沖
那他這種隔日沖就會導致東元怎麼樣
我們來看一下
東元早上就特別的弱
你看早上從47.45
殺到46.2
明明是大漲盤
對 明明大漲盤
通常我們這種全震賣壓都到10點
到10點就結束了
就賣光光了
他全震到10點就賣的差不多了
那後面怎麼樣呢
就看當天的行情
因為那天開地走高大盤大漲
所以東元那天這個尾盤還是有上漲所以假設你是有東元的你可以早上9點哇開高啊 昨天有全震買那麼多
早上9點先獲利了結一趟
先走一趟
然後10點發現真的跌回來了
再買回來
那你的持股數目都沒有變啊
因為5月16號是比較特別
就是大漲盤
要不然你有說根據前一天其實盤不好
所以那些全震買超的金額並沒有到非常大
照理來說他可能會一路落下去才對
機會比較高
假如那天是開高走低的話
他可能一直往下跌
好 這是東元
那這個東元我們就來看看他的走勢
好 走勢在這邊
各位看一下這個
全鎮大買
這邊有個全鎮多空
這個全鎮多空這邊會有個大長榜
隔天還會賣
那全鎮多空就會影響到自營商避險
自行商買 自行商隔天就會賣
那這檔股票又是主力在賣的
所以通常隔天
隔天它都會有個上影線
或者是會變成黑K
股票常常會這樣
所以這個是用線型來看
用線型來看
剛剛我有看到第二名
第二名好像你有做圖
第二名 6712常勝
我們就拿兩名來說
雖然買超金額不多
但不好意思你第二名
對 579
對這檔股票而言也算多了
因為這場成交量沒那麼大
那我們來看一下
他這個579萬
隔天一早也是一堆賣購
一堆賣購
全方位看到一堆賣購的訊號
那我們看一下
隔天是台子期漲180
漲超多
那我們來看一下長勝是誰買的呢
來看長勝
長勝5月15號
元富三戰七
元富松德70
所以這也是短線的分點
那我們可以看他的行為
你看就是這個時常都隔日衝
時常隔日衝
那了解他時常都隔日衝
我們就可以在隔天一早做什麼事呢
各位看一下
好快目的了結囉
假設你有這張股票的話
隔天一早開高還有223
對
我想說今天全正會賣
先賣一趟
後面低點有到212
對
結果當天大盤漲很多
他也是漲大上去
一直在盤下
都在盤下
數一數二的弱
真的耶
所以他前一天呢
哇 前一天
我看到它那麼強
昨天一早去追的話 完蛋了
因為你不曉得全證賣壓的節奏
我們說做股票要有節奏
節奏我們就是看自營商避險
好 看自營商避險
所以常常自營商跟投信外資不同掉
都是有原因的
這些大戶很壞耶
他們是逼別人做工耶
對啊
因為他們長期下來
他們賺錢的方法就是這些
那我們來看
我來看這一檔
在這一天
長勝大漲嘛
5月15號長勝大漲
主力買外資買
投信買
自行商大買
那全證呢
做多
結果隔天呢發生什麼事情
隔天連投信都隔日衝
哈哈哈哈
投信也被嚇到了
好悲慘啊
想說怎麼會
這麼弱
外資隔日衝就算了
因為外資常常隔日衝
因為有那個假的隔日衝在外資裡面
投信隔日衝還蠻少見的
其實我覺得蠻辛苦的就是說
應該是說投信會買它
是它第一季的財報其實好像還不錯
可是每場一買進來好像發情怪怪的
隔音就燙到
不過這個投信可能不是昨天買的
可能是因為它之前投信都買
對對對
結果變成波段的隔天倒出來
看起來很像隔日充
那自行商就常隔日充
那這種你看三大法蘭都隔日充
隔天就黑K機率很高
所以我们常常都去观察
自行商避险的节奏
自行商避险呢
大买隔天通常都会黑黑比较多
是 好
所以小哥的解说
大家有听懂吗
最直接的
每天晚上光顾一下
小哥的粉丝团
都会把主力全镇的买卖超排行榜
贴在上面
但是节奏要记牢哦
今天有公布了几个分点
不要怪我们哦
去怪小哥
这几个分点也不会轻易换
小哥有讲原因哦
如果你发现是他们在买的话
隔天反而賣壓會出籠
反之呢
如果他們在賣呢
隔天搞不好買盤會回籠
這個節奏要抓好
所以呢
想要再多學一點嗎
請訂閱我們的榮耀班
在榮耀班裡面
小豬會來告訴你
現在有哪一些的個股
很值得你鎖股做觀察
因為我知道大家都還是有一點點的依賴
講完了例子
還是希望你舉一些
我可以拿來觀察的例子
會比較容易上手
by bwd6